[Musique]
bonsoir Didier Ringo vous êtes donc le
délégué CGT sur ce site de véisi
d'Alcatel Lucent vous avez appris en fin
de semaine la suppression de ces 1430
postes en France euh près de 5500 postes
hein dans le monde quelle était
l'ambiance aujourd'hui lorsqu'il a fallu
retourner au travail ce lundi matin sur
le site de Vézy ben on est encore un peu
dans l'expectative parce que on ne
connaît pas encore le le détail des
suppressions de postes par site euh
maintenant sur vellisie on sait bien que
le site va être frappé très lourdement
parce que les fonctions qui sont visées
par ce ces suppressions de postees c'est
en grande partie les fonctions
commerciales qui sont très représentées
à véisi donc on s'attend à ce que le
site
soit un des des plus frappés par les
suppressions de postes il y a à peu près
2000 salariés sur ce site de véisi on
parlerait d'un d'un tiers des postes de
supprimé et puis les autres donc se
rejoindrai les autres salariés
rejoindrai un autre site site situé dans
les sones oui donc c'est le site de
nasé donc c'est à 25 km de de
vellisi on sait bien que 25 km en région
parisienne ça représente une grosse
différence en terme de de temps de
transport euh d'autant que le site de
véizi c'est un site historique de
d'Alcatel il il existe depuis une
quarantaine d'années les gens sont sont
installés plutôt à proximité du s voir
pour
certains bien plus loin puisque il y a
eu déjà beaucoup de transferts et de
fermeture de sites à
Alcatel il y a des des collègues qui
viennent quand même de de sergie de de
nanter de colombe qui sont installés
très loin de très loin de vézi et qui
seront encore plus loin de Villarceau
sur ce rassemblement justement des des
deux sites ce rassemblement vers les
sonnes le site de vézi et qui
fusionnerait avec celui de lesesson nous
avons rencontré à ce sujet Stéphane
dubled il est également délégué syndical
CGT il siège au Comité central
d'entreprise il réagit à cette idée de
regroupement impossible à réaliser selon
lui il a la fermeture du site qui nous
est présenté comme étant une chance pour
la France
avec en constituant un gros un énorme
site en France mais bon très clairement
c'est des questions de cûp qui président
à ce truc ils espèrent économiser 17
millions d'euros par an sur ce sur cette
opération il y a des problèmes à la fois
des problèmes humains et des problèmes
opérationnels pour le les produits que
tout ce qu'on fait typiquement on ne
comprend pas comment ce serait possible
dans le délai qu' leur est qu'ils nous
ont apparti sur ce truc il ils pense
faire ça d'ici mi 2013 et d'ici 2013 il
faut qu'il dépose un permis de
construire qu'il obtiennent qui
bâtissent les bâtiments qui qu'ils
agrandissent la cantine de de de
l'établissement de nasé et cetera et
cetera qui déménagent les maquettes il y
a il y a actuellement 8000 m² de
maquette ici ils envisagent de
construire là-bas 3000 m² de maquette
supplémentaire mais enfin bref tout ça
pour dire que ça me semble pas très
réaliste alors ça semble impossible à
réaliser pour le délégué syndical qu'on
vient d'entendre pour vous également ça
semble difficile de réaliser cette
fusion ce sera difficile ce sera et ce
sera
pénible effectivement ça ça va avoir un
impact sur le sur le travail qui qui qui
n'arrangera pas la situation
d'entreprise comment vous allez vous
organiser pour Mobil éventuellement
est-ce qu'il y a une certaine
résignation également qui s qui s'est
installé pour l'instant on attend un peu
quand même de de voir comment ça comment
ça va se se
passer vous pensez mobiliser manifester
on on peut aussi élargir un petit peu
par rapport à Alcatel sur le site même
de vé la situation est compliquée du
côté de PSA du côté de Tal également
vous allez mobiliser les autres salariés
on va essayer effectivement de de voir
avec les entrepris prise de vellisi qui
sont dans le même cas que nous si on
peut mener des des actions communes
parce que bah là on voit c'est partout
le le même problème dans ces entreprises
c'est c'est les salariés qui trinquent
pour les difficultés réelles ou supposé
des entreprise et comment vous expliquez
justement cet échec qui qui aboutit
aujourd'hui à ces suppressions de
postees principalement en Europe et en
France euh ben il y a eu une politique
depuis des années de se recentrer sur ce
que l'ancien PDG appelé le le cœur de
métier dans le groupe qui était à
l'époque Alcatel Alstom qui s'est
recentré sur les télécoms
euh
donc quand quand les télécoms
marchent le groupe fait fait de bons
résultat mais après une fois que si le
le marché les marchés se se réduisent on
a plus que a des mauvais choix
stratégiques qui ont été fait par la
direction il y a eu probablement des
mauvais choix stratégiques maintenant
nous notre problème c'est pas de
d'assumer justement ces erreurs
stratégiques c'est de d'empêcher que ce
soit les les salariés qui trainquent
pour pour ces erreurs et du côté des
politiques Valérie pcres qui est député
UMP député d'opposition de cette deuxème
circonscription des ivelines où se
trouve la ville de véis elle a annoncé
elle est également elle siège également
au conseil régional d'î-de-france elle a
demandé au pouvoir public d'agir au plus
vite pour le maintien des emplois est-ce
que vous attendez un soutien
véritablement des politiques est-ce que
vous les avez déjà alerté est-ce qu'il
vous écoutent euh on avait déjà
rencontré enfin l'intersyndical avait
rencontré Fleur Pellerin
euh peu après le l'annonce des 5000
suppressions d'emploi au niveau mondial
euh aujourd'hui tout ce qu'on tout ce
qu'on voit c'est un plan de soutien à la
filière
euh ça malheureusement c'est ce qui
s'était fait aussi pour pour
l'automobile en
2008 l'État avait offert 3 milliards
d'euros à Renault et 3 milliard d'euros
à PSA aujourd'hui on voit que ces deux
groupesat licenci euh il faut quand même
arrêter de donner de l'argent public à
des à des entreprises privées qui qui
s'en servent à la limite pour financer
leur plan licenciement
donc il faudrait au contraire que le que
l'État prenne des mesures pour pour
empêcher ces licenciements et soit du
côté des salariés et non pas du côté des
entreprises on va écouter à présent
Jean-Philippe m' laissé le député
socialiste de la 11e circonscription des
ivel nous l'avons rencontré il réagit à
ses suppressions de postes et il estime
également que des mesures pourraient
être prises au niveau européen moi je
serai à la disposition évidemment s'il
le souhaite les salariés de véisie pour
pour intervenir pour les aider pour
contribuer à ce que à ce que des choses
puissent être faites François Hollande a
a mis en place un certain nombre de de
propositions avancé un certain nombre de
propositions en faveur de de l'emploi
hein bon les emplois d'avenir les
contrats de génération et cetera moi je
pense qu'au niveau européen par exemple
il y a des choses à faire pour pour pour
réguler l'économie pour protéger les
pays européens face à la mondialisation
qui est souvent une mondialisation qui
est qui est comment dire inéquitable
hein pour évidemment pour pour les pays
européens on voit bien qu'on on ne lutte
pas dans cette concurrence mondiale avec
les les mêmes armes donc je pense qu'au
niveau européen il y a des choses à
faire moi je ne suis pas du tout
partisan du du fait de dire les
politiques sont impuissant vous pensez
qu'au niveau européen des mesures
peuvent être prises également pour
protéger les emplois en France ou en
Allemagne aussi l'Allemagne est touché
la Belgique l'Espagne par ses
suppressions de postees du côté
d'Alcatel ça va jouer au niveau européen
aussi ça peut jouer au niveau européen
mais enfin de toute façon je pense que
les
gouvernements le gouvernement en France
a les moyens lui de prendre des mesures
pour empêcher les licenciement euh après
vous ce que vous demandez aujourd'hui
c'est une interdiction des licenciement
interdiction des licenciements et
justement pas utiliser l'argent public
pour pour soutenir une entreprise qui
licencie il faut que le le le chantage
qui nous est fait
sur le crédit impôt recherche par
exemple où le directeur général se
réjouit que en France il le crédit impôt
recherche il faut il faut le faut le
retourner parce que on peut pas
continuer de de dire on on verse de
l'argent à des entreprises alors
que il suppriment des emplois merci
didiergo délégué CGT sur ce site de de
véisi prochaine étape pour les
syndicalistes réunion ce jeudi cette
semaine pour faire le point notamment
sur les mouvements d'Action éventuels à
entamer sur ce site de véis après
l'annonce de la fermeture et puis les
suppressions de postes à travers
l'Europe et à travers la France plus
particulièrement merci à vous à
l'association média handicap
partenairire comme tous les ans de la
Semaine du handicap à Montini le
Bretonneux son objectif changer le
regard sur le handicap à travers le
soutien notamment de personnalité cette
année le mannequin Noémi le noir a
participé à la manifestation on va te
faire goûter autre chose alors que
s'ouvre la semaine du handicap à plaisir
elle se referme sur Montini comme chaque
année depuis 9 ans la Ville souhaite
sensibiliser le jeune public au handicap
la manifestation s'achève toujours par
un dimanche de mise en pratique d'un
côté l'association handigrimpe mené par
Philippe Ribière derrière nous il y a
l'association ciel et l'association
handigrimp qui font grimper des des
personnes valides ave des handicaps
artificiell main attaché pied attachés
yeux bandés et on a aussi eu une
démonstration avec les membres de
l'équipe de France
paracing de l'autre l'association méia
Handicap mise en place par
sébastienard le but cétait de faire
triathlon de l'espérance le triathlon de
l'espérance c'est trois défis en
situation de handicap donc les
situations de handicap c'est une
situation en faute roulant ils partent
avec le parcours en faute roulant après
ils doivent lancer la balle dans un pan
de pasqu et après il continue vers des
obstacles et après il commence le
pingpong elloïse par exemple s'est
essayé au fauteuil roulant cette jeune
in Montaine de 9 ans a incité sa maman à
faire le parcours j'ai vu que en passant
par la porte c'est pas c'est dur et pour
les personnes toujours en fauteuil
roulant ça doit être dur c'est bien oui
que tout le monde puisse un jour se dire
moi je j'ai la chance de de pouvoir
marcher de d'être en bonne santé
maintenant l'équipe d'une dizaine de
bénévoles a préparé le parcours de mise
en situation de handicap sous le regard
attentif de Noémie Lenoir marine
d'honneur de l'association les plus
grand difficulté c'est en fauteuil
roulant donc quand on fait le défi
là-bas d'ouvrir une porte de passer un
trottoir ou quelque chose comme ça c'est
bien parce que cette cette association
est est aujourd'hui ça permet vraiment
de voir ce que les handicapés vivent
tous les jours il y a des évolutions de
mentalité mais il faut tout le temps
faire mettre en place des actions pour
que ça ça se
pérénise en 2013 la semaine du handicap
de Montini fêtera ces 10 ans de quoi
dresser un bilan sur les actions menées
autour du handicap voà et là c'est
prépar